Sheila and Luana realized that they
could express their ages more
specifically if they used fractions
doing this will allow them to calculate
the difference in their ages more
precisely if Sheila describes her age as
fifteen and a half years old and Luana
is seven and seven twelfths I'm assuming
years old what is the difference in
their ages the difference in their ages
write the answer as a simplified mixed
number so Sheila is older so she is
fifteen and a half years old so we
really want to find the difference
between fifteen and a half and seven and
seven twelve and we can see immediately
or maybe it's not obvious to you but one
half is the same thing as six twelve
which is less than seven twelve so if we
separate out the whole number parts and
the fraction parts the fractions this
fraction is actually smaller the one
half is smaller than the seven twelve so
it might be easier to just do this as
mixed numbers so we don't have to do all
of that borrowing and regrouping so
let's write both of them as mixed
numbers so we have 15 and 1/2 we're
still going to our sorry let's write
both them as improper fractions so we're
going to keep two in the denominator and
as an improper fraction two times 15 is
30 plus one is 31 so 31 over two is the
same thing as 15 and 1/2 so these are
equivalent and then 7 + 7 12 so if we
write it as an improper fraction so
we're gonna still have the minus sign
out there the denominator is 12 12 times
7 is 84 84 plus seven is 91 it is 91 did
I do that right
91 yep that looks right 91 over 12 now
we've written both of them as improper
fractions but we still have different
denominators so we have to have a common
denominator so what is the least common
multiple of 2 and 12 or what's the
smallest number that's divisible by both
of them well 12 is divisible by 12 and
12 is also divisible by 2 so 12 is the
least common multiple
so we want both of them to be over 12
over 12 and this fraction already is
over 12 so we don't have to change it 91
over 12 now on the blue one to go from 2
to 12 in the denominator we have to
multiply by 6 so we also have to
multiply by 6 in the numerator so if we
multiply 31 31 by 6 what do we get you
can even do this in your head 6 times 30
is 180 6 times 1 is 6 so it's going to
be 186 and now we subtract so our the
difference in their ages is going to be
it's going to be the denominator is
going to be 12 it's going to be 186 - 91
which is equal to over 12 see 186 - just
90 would be 96 for it we my subtracting
91 so it's going to be 95 95 right 6
minus 1 is 5 and then 180 minus 90 is 90
so that works out so the way we've
expressed it right now it is just it is
an improper fraction but they want us to
write it as a simplified mixed number so
let's do that so how many times just 12
go into 95 let's see 12 8 times 12 is 96
so that's too big so 12 goes 7 times so
this is so this is equal to 7 and then
if we take let me write it out if we
want to do too much in your head if we
go 12 into 95 I'm saying it goes 7 times
so if that's true if that's the largest
number then the remainder should be less
than 12 7 times 12 we know is 84 from
our times tables or you could just think
it's going to be 14 plus 10 times 7
which is 70 either way and I see 95
minus 84 5 minus 4 is 1 9 minus 8 is 1
so we have a remainder of 11 so 12 goes
into 95 seven times you get 7 holes and
you have 11 left over so 95 over 12
of is seven and eleven twelve and we're
done the difference between Sheila and
Luana's age is seven and eleven twelve
or Sheila is seven and eleven twelve
years older than Luana